en estambul hoy se abre el centro para
la coordinación para exportar el grano
cráneo que saldrá a partir de los
próximos días de los puertos de ucrania
según firmaron la semana pasada el
gobierno de turquía junto con los
gobiernos crearon el ruso con navegación
también de naciones unidas según ha
explicado el ministro de defensa turco
está hace unos minutos en turquía youlus
sacar el trigo se exportará y se irá
garantizando el paso el paso de todos
los cargueros granos con trigo desde
este mismo centro en el que cada día a
día durante los próximos 120 días las
delegaciones rusa y negociarán los pasos
de estos cargueros que tendrán que salir
y ser controlados ha dicho el ministro
turco en los puertos de turquía ha dicho
a car que los barcos que saldrán primero
de los puertos soberanos llegarán a los
puertos turcos y ahí serán monitoreadas
sus cargas y vigiladas que no sean
exportados ni importados a productos de
armamento ni municiones a ucrania
en la condición primaria que debemos
considerar en la seguridad de la
navegación de los barcos por lo tanto
obviamente esto es lo que estamos
teniendo en cuenta
al acuerdo cubre el grano y derivados de
alimentos y también los fertilizantes
esto es lo que la iniciativa cubre hasta
donde deriva el acuerdo y cuantos más
productos se podrán exportar eso está
por determinar
[Música]
espera rusia que después del
establecimiento de este a este centro se
levantarán las sanciones occidentales
pondrá su trigo y productos de
fertilizante que espera a que suelen ser
en los próximos días algo que será
hablado la semana que viene cuando
erdogán visite al presidente ruso
vladimir putin en la ciudad rusa de
sochi